welcome to your mom's house
here's a tremendous boxer Aamir Khan who
actually he was at recently I think I
could pull this up is it Chaka Khan's
cousin for me just for me
that was really rough here's Aamir Khan
and crazy looks why the fuck
oh really okay oh shit this motherfucker
got a sword Jews Aamir Khan recently
right here what crazy look shut up yeah
so crazy looked at his gym and Aamir
Khan's everybody tremendous boxer look
how Amir thinks everything is cool and
then you can see it he slowly looks that
crazy looks like okay pal so here's a
mere person trying to be an older fight
but this is him in the ring it looks
like maybe you look right after a fight
had ended shit your waist but goodness
me how hard you have to work through an
that oh yeah you mean very hard this is
a professional game no you know it's not
gonna be easy first major title I won't
get my 13 fight and to do it it means
wicked you will either great fire now I
mean you can take no credit away from
him because it's a great great fire
yummy who's strongest kept going forward
the skillful
well yeah enjoy the I mean I love being
there I mean nobody where 12 wounds I
was just moving it every minute so
interesting to hear you know I mean with
that accent right well I wasn't
expecting that accent to come out of
that face
oh yeah that's the last accent I would
have expected what did you expect from
America just like American oh really
it's just like Chaka Khan's cuz I'm
about to remember looks at Laurel man
like went to the brink though you went
to the Brinker one stage it looks you're
gonna lose that fight when you were down
no yeah I mean I spoke to you for yummy
one change it could've changed me boy I
mean I sure the good chin and I could
come back for me yeah I mean I mean what
was going on you know I mean I when I
did yummy this might be a record-setting
omein find as far as as they go I don't
know and this crosses genre I mean
you've got a white guy who went as a
boxer and he's saying you know he's not
a white guy what are you talking about
well what is he talk that guy looks like
a white guy too you know
are you serious right now I didn't want
to guess cuz then a million songs will
be made and clips will be isolated well
I mean what part of Aamir Khan's look it
says white I don't know I mean what is
he then Tom I'm gonna guess he is a
Pakistani descent now he is yeah okay so
he yeah but he's obviously British Ray's
right yeah is it but why don't you do
the master of accents aren't you then is
he British yeah he's a born in which
region do you hear though I hear I had
Manchester Manchester wanted Manchester
Manchester Manchester Manchester just
not back
Birmingham Manchester lawn Chester wrong
sister you know I mean yeah I mean yeah
I mean see I did a perfect that's
perfect I mean yeah I mean yeah I mean
yummy yummy well monastic yeah I mean
Manchester but I mean yeah I mean who
put on that's on me but I just compose
myself and just pick the right shots
shots
I like the video you
pick out a lot of mistakes when you go
right for you oh yeah I think the timing
just wasn't there yeah I mean but I'm
just I'm just wanting to commit myself
too much you I mean no I mean just job
than working myself you know give us all
in all the way buying is a mesh you know
I mean you know me do your deer it's a
bit of a whiffle that's a powerful
weapon in it fresh I mean I mean I mean
I mean good I think because in your
world they're all different
yeah he might as Emir's risen to the top
as far as you know I mean you know he's
the king of you know what I means yeah
this guy set the bar super high super
high it's gonna really take a strong
opponent the same way it does in the
ring to differ on Amir Khan from you
know I mean title this white guy Amir
Khan I'm sorry
fight and he's Pakistani which is unique
I don't think we've ever had a Pakistani
you know what I mean she's number one
he's a lieutenant you know I mean for
Pakistani people we've never had that
yeah absolutely
generally you know same yeah no no I'd
write oh yeah yeah you know what I mean
well